i want to talk to you today about
um observability at the long tail
um and kind of so we talk about
observability uh we have we deal with
really large data um and so
we
inevitably take some techniques to kind
of reduce the complication of that data
but that can really hurt our ability to
kind of understand
uh the you know 95th percentile or the
99th
percentile of our data
and so
i want to talk about some popular
techniques that people use
and we can talk about when they work
when they don't work and then i'll
introduce you to
kind of a large swath of research
that comes out of the databases and the
theoretical computer science community
that really thinks about this in kind of
streaming use cases the kind of use
cases that we have if i'm in lots of
production systems
all right so um i am here
on behalf of y labs um we're on this
mission to kind of build an interface
between human
operators and ai applications
um so we have a
sas product that does kind of ai
observability and monitoring
um but what i really want to talk about
today um
is a thing that we're really proud of
and a thing that really is the core of
even our sas product
is why logs so this is an open source
library
it's really about kind of pulling the
right telemetry from your machine
learning data
and we'll talk about why it's so special
and kind of
how efficient it is and all of the
algorithmic work that kind of goes into
making this efficient as we kind of
ponder the case of the long tail and
rare events
okay
i'm happy to see this moving so so
production data is often
has high volume it's dynamic
so right you have more and more data
coming in
and increasingly in this kind of
streaming form it's coming in
continuously and the sorts of techniques
that you might have
from any machine learning or statistics
training may not work here because we're
used to maybe batch data or static data
we're holding it in memory we're doing
this processing
and there's certainly you know ways to
do that or to kind of distribute your
work
and and do the same sort use the same
sort of algorithms but i think
increasingly
production machine learning systems and
those who operate them
will think about the complexities of
scale
if they haven't already
and then the streaming data
and uh one thing is
if
not only thinking about the stream but
we also have
rare events so if you have dynamic data
like this
the the work it takes to kind of analyze
these data points and figure out which
of these data points are outliers
or
record information about these these
particular data points can be quite
interesting
so to grapple just handling the scale of
data
at all
there's a number of techniques that
people use so one
many practitioners use some sort of
simple sampling techniques so if you
have
you may retain kind of the full data set
for special use cases but there's lots
of companies and practitioners who just
can't retain every bit of data that
happens so they'll keep some sample
maybe it's a one percent sample
maybe more depending on you know the
size of the data that they have and
their their interest in retaining it um
and most use a very simple sampling
technique just a random sample of you
know one percent of the data that comes
through
um
others kind of move into the space of
slicing your data
into segments different ways to segment
and slice your data
largely based on time if we're thinking
about this
this kind of streaming use case
but then also other characteristics so
here i think i have
the different colors representing
um some
helpful characteristic you might split
it into let's say cities let's say we
have some some products that
may operate differently your data data
may look differently by city you may
want to split it in that way in addition
to splitting by time
um and when you split that there's some
analysis you can do on
these different sections
um and so we'll talk about what people
are often doing but i would call i would
characterize any time that you're
looking at a data
set and trying to understand
characteristics and maybe even then
store those characteristics
as profiling that data
okay so the rest of uh this talk well
there's kind of two parts this first
part is going to be about comparing
three techniques uh which i think are
the kind of the
certainly the first two are the
fundamental ones that people look to
when they're trying to
analyze streaming data or just large
amounts of data
for the first time the third one i will
try to do my best to convince you is a
more efficient one and kind of gives you
benefits from both sides
so
we're going to do this in the context of
kind of median and quantile calculations
so
what's the 50th percentile what's the
95th percentile what's the
0.1
percentile
all right so the first is
static metrics on subsets of data so
after we split this data into the number
of windows that we have
we may
simply kind of collect a
dictionary of important metrics that
we've determined ahead of time that we
want to calculate on it so
means medians maybe a certain number of
quantiles
min max if you have output data if this
is attached to a model and this is
inference you may have performance
metrics things like that
the next is so this is just storing that
those metrics and uh you may store you
know some subset of the data as well but
um as far as kind of where you do your
analysis you're just kind of basing it
on those metrics that you've stored
the second one is random sampling i mean
there's a number of sampling techniques
um and so i admit that um i think for a
more thorough analysis i would kind of
go into the details of different types
of sampling but here i'm just going to
keep it strictly random and this is kind
of what i see
a lot of people using um
so
just storing some random sample of the
data for further analysis you store it
in a database things like that i mean so
that what that means is that when i want
to go back and do some analysis on my
data i'm you know pulling that info down
or running this inside of my database on
the raw data in the in the same kind of
form
and finally
i'm also data profiling for streaming
data
so while the static metric collecting
static metrics can also be data
profiling
i want to really talk about kind of
particular data structures and
algorithms to collect
more detailed information about data as
it's streaming
that can better summarize
the data and comes with error bounds and
can handle these kind of
rare events better
okay
so let's get to an example of the first
one the first one is capturing
these simple
pre-collected
pre-selected metrics for machine
learning data so some benefits
is that once you've collected let's say
some metrics like this that i'm showing
to the left
it's really fast to do analysis on this
so you you have a list of metrics you
can pull them up i think there's a
number of different tools that allow you
to kind of store metrics in this sort of
form i see it in kind of feature stores
i see it sometimes in
kind of experiment management tools
things like that i mean it's really
convenient to now go back and search
across all of these because it's just a
small dictionary often
because it's a small dictionary it also
has low storage size so this can be
really beneficial relative to
you know the large amount of data and
storage that you may need if you're
storing actual data
this is this is quite small actually
it's quite small by any standard
um
and another benefit that you won't see
for the others is that these act these
metrics that you calculate at least with
respect to the subset that you've
determined are
exact
so if once i calculate this i'm using a
standard kind of algorithm to calculate
mean median and these sorts of things
you likely have exact values
so some cons um one con is that uh you
have to determine these metrics ahead of
time
um so if you haven't picked any
metrics or there's some metrics that you
want to include later um perhaps they're
kind of business kpis or
other metrics that you want to use for
your model um you can't go back and well
you can't go back and recalculate them
just based on this approach alone you'd
have to have stored that data or stored
a sample of that data to try to estimate
it
um and lastly i will talk a lot about
this in a little bit but
it's non-mergeable and mergeability is
going to be really important
for a number of things for kind of your
ability to have flexible analysis later
and
the lack of mergibility will really
really make it difficult for you to
understand anything about the tail of
your data in aggregate
yeah yeah i think that would still fit
if um if you yes if you have
multiple variables yeah i think this
whole thing is pretty much kind of
univariate that i'm doing this on
but no reason to be other than
simplicity
okay so here's a number of questions
that you would want to answer um but you
can't really answer um depending on the
the metrics that you chose for a static
approach
so um
does the estimated value
of a new metric that i've come up with
uh what does that look like on prior
data right we can't get that
when i start to think about maybe new
things like overlap of
this data with some
set of important values
relative rank of this value on
last year's data so if this is some sort
of aggregation
the drift between two data sets so
something like this if you look
to the right
you have
kind of the first part of the ks
statistic which is a popular way to
measure
a distribution drift
and so what you need there are two cdfs
and you need the you need basically the
maximum distance between the two cdfs
and you take that
and you find a statistic on it um
kolmogorov
and then you can get some sense of
whether or not these things are drift or
or just statistically or perhaps um and
so this is the thing you couldn't
calculate really
if you're collecting pre-selected
metrics
in this way
and then error-bound so kind of more
complex ways of thinking about the error
that would result from this and many
more
and
a large reason for some of the problems
with this approach is that it lacks the
ability to merge the data together
so
um for one for one thing if you have a
stream of data you likely don't even
have fixed bins um and so that makes
merge ability hard on its own
but even so
your your ability to
merge multiple of these um
these pre selected kind of sets of
static metrics uh can really really hurt
your ability to do this rare
long tail analysis
so i'm going to go over random sampling
a bit and then we can dig into kind of
more of the the deep analysis stuff here
um so i'm just going to trim this a
little bit
so random sampling of machine learning
data has issues as well
so on the left um it's formatted a
little differently but um it's just
a kind of the first couple rows of a csv
just to highlight that like you do have
data in the same form that of your
original data and that is one of the
first benefits because
your data scientists know how to
interact with this data they probably
already have scripts to interact with
this data in this form
and that can be highly beneficial
it's also highly flexible so
even if it is a random sample and it has
some problems on outliers that we'll
talk about in a bit
it
it allows you to calculate any metric
later that you want and that can be
really beneficial
um
it can work for batch or streaming data
depending on
sometimes people get into trouble if
they try to pick
a fixed number of data points as opposed
to a percentage
because in that case you need to do
something like reservoir sampling it's
just a little more complicated on
getting kind of
a
an equally
distributed
sample if you have a fixed amount but it
does work on streaming data or batch um
and it's mergeable there's rows in a
cell so you could add a new column have
a date and merge them however you'd like
um some issues with this
um is that
we'll talk about in a bit with some
experiments uh kind of poor estimates on
the tail and outliers
and poor precision
depending on the percentage of the data
that you are taking as a sample
and then high storage size this is just
full data
especially if you're calculating some
simple metrics in the future
may not be worth it
okay so what is this third option that
i'm
sort of proposing
well it fits into the umbrella of data
profiling as i mentioned
and so data profiling is really just the
act of reviewing and analyzing a data
set to understand the structure and
information
often what comes out of it is kind of a
collection of descriptive statistics
similar to what we saw in the first
the first option
and there's lots of normally there's
lots of kind of detection things so you
might detect the data types um
patterns data structures
you may have like outlier detection a
lot of other models have data quality
examinations so something like great
expectations or or the equivalent
but
these data profiling
techniques can get more advanced i mean
that's what we do over at y labs and
what i want to talk about today
so these are some things that we either
have or can
are kind of actively developing inside
of this data profiling process
i mean this includes things like
error bounds so we do have error bounds
on all of the
the estimates that we have
which are really i think important
we also have things like feature
importance you can include feature
importance um we're starting to include
outlier detection so as a process during
the streaming profiling process
and a number of things you can create
like a surrogate model to go on top of
your data and so on
okay so this is uh what i'm going to
focus on and what we do at ylabs and
what i think is really an approach that
helps you at the tail
for rare events
so
this is sketch based data profiling
i mean so we'll talk a bit about data
sketches but essentially they are a
number of algorithms to create very
very efficient data structures
that can
look at the data only once so
in a kind of streaming form or online
format
and there's a number of things that we
can collect
some benefits to the sketching based
data profiling are you still have fast
access to key metrics similar to the
kind of
static data profiles
you have high flexibility maybe not the
same flexibility that you have with raw
data but you do have higher flexibility
it's very low in memory and storage size
unlike the kind of static metrics it is
mergeable and that's really key to
understanding rare events
it's built on kind of a large academic
literature which i think is great
um and something that um is important to
reuse database so databases underneath
the hood
uh most databases these days use
sketches because there
there's a lot of cases where you can get
away with kind of approximate
um
subsets and things like that as opposed
to kind of
the exact count
some cons so there's some pre-selection
that happens um
you
these sketches kind of involve
complex algorithms underneath the hood
and so i'm
translating those algorithms to a
particular metric may take a little bit
of work or at least deciding that you
want to include that into your profile
okay
so we learned all of this i don't think
any of us knew this at the time um
about these
data sketches and sketching techniques
when we were setting out to build kind
of a standard for profiling machine
learning data so we also started with
those static data
those static metrics
but we really wanted these five
properties lightweight
which you can certainly get configurable
which is fine emergibility isn't a key
component
so streaming being able to work on
streaming data and something that's
statistically sound um so we thought
well if we collect metrics and then we
do some weighted average across them
that doesn't really tell us kind of what
the bounds are
for our estimates or when we can tell we
can we can only estimate them at a
pretty
not exciting level a very very wide
bounds
um and so this is um largely our tools
are largely powered by apache data
sketches which is an open source data
sketching library
all right now for math i'm sorry that i
i made you guys wait 28 minutes until
the math
um
so now let's talk about how
median and quantiles work i mean we'll
start in the box to the right
um
actually no let's start to the left
and then we'll and then we'll do the
example to the right here so um for
stream of numbers so we're getting a
stream of numbers x1 x2 so on and so
forth
with the current stream length in so n
is going to continue to
to
tick up increment every time we get a
new data point and for stream um in the
streaming setting we have no idea when
the stream's going to stop we can't like
we can't say how many data points we're
going to eventually see this is going to
harm us in a little bit
um but that's okay um so
some notation for
rank and quantile because i find that
even i got them backwards sometimes
until i had to write it down in this way
so a rank of x tells you kind of of a
sorted list or of a list um how many of
the elements just encount
are less than the value have a value
less than
this x
um
relative rank which is sometimes used
just for the word rank um or is just
normalized by the number of um elements
that you saw so between zero and one
quantile uh quantum what it tells you is
the va the value
such that the rank of some data
is set to is equal to this quantile
um or i should say the relative rank is
equal to this quantile so for example
uh let's look at the right if i have
values in a stream five four one five
six two
the first thing that we would do if we
were trying to calculate a median is
sort them
so we sort them one two four five five
six
um and then we can say well the rank of
the number four is three
because there are three elements that
are
two that are less than and one including
itself so that's three
the relative rank is just three out of
six
um although i guess if we it depends on
when we ask for these ranks um but i'm
assuming at the end of these six data
points that i've given you
um and then the quantile so the the um
quantile at 0.5
is the number four
or someone say 4.5 it kind of depends
um on how you're defining that there
when you're split
but we're going to go with four so
there's kind of a less than
a greater than approach to thinking
about quantiles and we're going to go
with the less than approach here
all right
so
rapidly increasing in the math here
let's talk about
exact calculations of this on streaming
data so i mean calculating a median
isn't that bad we've all done it take
some data sort it you know find out how
many are in front of it um
but it gets much harder if you think
about it in a streaming setting because
it it
so monroe patterson actually proved that
um it the
kind of it takes into the one over p
um amounts of data points that you have
to hold in memory
to find the exact median um or any
quantile so for example
if we wanted to do this in one pass if
we if we only see the data once it's
coming in um
like uh
yeah and so we only see the data once um
then p is one
and so we need to hold in data points we
need to hold every single data point to
get the exact median because otherwise
we won't know right like so uh in the
worst case scenario you
you know see five data points you say
okay there's no way i'm going to need
either of these two n's and then you get
a bunch of zeros
right and so now you needed all of those
numbers at the end so you have to hold
all of these
and the way that calculating quantiles
work kind of underneath the hood for
anything that you've run in memory is
they take multiple passes to do this
right so you can go you can kind of
filter this down
um and now that we filter it down we
know kind of the the max and men and we
can continue to filter down until we get
to the middle quantile
um so this takes quite a
bit of space
if you're trying to do this in one pass
but approximate calculations are where
you will want to go if you're trying to
calculate
anything quantile related
for streaming data
and data sketching techniques allow us
to do this
so there are numerous algorithms
i won't go into these but i will say i'm
just looking at the space requirements
for a single quantile
so one over epsilon uh log log squared
one over epsilon delta or sorry one over
i have those flipped one over delta um
and then if i want to do this for all
quantiles right uh because we don't want
to just calculate the median we want to
know again what's the 99th
quantile what's the 99.98
quantile all of those things uh then
it's um
multiplied from that
okay so i won't go through this in
detail um
but i just want to give a kind of
an appreciation for how these kind of
algorithms work to approximate uh the
quantiles uh so um
largely it's just really simplified
um sampling
combined with some numbers that you keep
track of so you can understand the error
and um give better estimates about
quantiles that you dropped or or don't
have in your set so if you see the top
row there's seven
elements added and this kind of dotted
lines going down are queries that we're
going to make in a little bit later
um so the the way that this works is
kind of a compaction technique um
basically you have a buffer uh you might
take in six data points and then once
you have those six data points you will
drop a number of data points um and keep
track of
um how many you've dropped or like the
number of
compactions that you've done
and so you'll see this kind of two
number come up here
and then you might do that again or
multiple times
to get even more compact and this is how
the file size gets so small
that you're able to do these multiple
compactions um and still kind of
maintain a good estimate as long as
we're keeping track of some information
about
um
the number of compactions and the nature
of those compactions
all right
um
so
i i'm going to maybe step back out for a
bit um before we jump into the
experiments um and just talk about um
profiling and when you would do this
sort of um sketch based profiling
so we find that we do it both on kind of
training data or static
data sets and in this case it's mostly
to
just reduce the file size and have kind
of a format in which we can collect all
of these interesting metrics
without reanalyzing the data very often
on our kind of large training set
although that's normally pretty doable
training
data
is normally large enough you have a
machine large enough to process it of
course because you've trained a model on
it
so the big use case is profiling ongoing
production data
where we're creating these batches maybe
once per hour once for five minutes once
per day
and the cool thing about having these is
so if i separate these out one by day in
this picture
um
in the next month i may decide okay well
last month's data i don't need that that
granular i'm going to reduce and merge
together each week
um to save some space and i can do that
so on and so forth so i can have data
from five years ago that maybe is at the
monthly level despite me collecting it
at the daily or five minute level um in
real time and that's a huge benefit of
uh the mergibility
um so we're gonna kind of look um at a
single profile so there's lots of cool
things that you can do with multiple
starting to think about kind of drift
detection and these sorts of things and
monitoring but we're just focused at the
single profile now
and i want to talk about specifically
data sampling versus profiling
um and comparing the error at the tail
so we finally got there
um
and so this is a bit of the experimental
procedure um just random sampling a
number of data records
um we're taking
the subset of records based off of what
percentage we've set
um comparing that exact value uh so for
things like the median or
i'm the 95th percentile
running it a total of 24 times and
averaging those results
okay so we're going to do it on a number
of distributions
some distributions are probably very
familiar to you normal distribution
uniform distribution
discretized normal
and uniform so
discrete values uh categorical data sort
of style
but i'm going to add one more in here
which is the lomax or the pareto type ii
distribution
uh so this has a bit of a
fat tail the traditional pareto
distribution uh kind of has its peak at
one uh but this uh the pareto type two
or the low max starts uh well i think
has a starts at zero typically and i
think
pareto you can give a parameter for
where it's going to be but this is what
it looks like it's a little hard to tell
that the tail is fat unless you look at
normal distributions a lot
but it's a much fatter tale than uh you
might see on a lot of other
distributions
um okay so here's some experiments uh so
this is um in blue
um are the kind of results from doing
this sketch based profiling
and in orange are the results from
sampling
and the longer the bar the worse it is
because this is error so for median if
we want to take our data which i think
was
a hundred thousand samples
um and
um
and calculate the median uh using kind
of
a sample of this and then comparing it
to the actual median on the true data
you see kind of pretty large error
that's relative but uh so 0.1
for normal distribution
so on and so forth
the so for pareto and uniform i have
these in relative error which is
probably easier here
so 0.1 for
sampling and a little under half of that
for
profiling yeah
yes i did did i detail this on here
oh i so yeah i think i skipped over it
as far as saying it but it's number two
on here so what i did is um
i um subset some number of records
that's equivalent to the number of bytes
of the profile
no no that's okay i don't think i read
it either
i skipped the big paragraphs um so yeah
so um that's why that's why i don't have
an exact number for the sample because
there are some fixed costs for the
profile size and i wanted to match those
um and so now we start to see the 95th
percentile
and we see some some larger differences
here
and
looking at the tail is really difficult
and one reason is this even for
sketching
so we can kind of get low rank error so
this is some results from a much newer
sketching technique for quantiles
and ping mesh is the name of a microsoft
server data set
but we can get quite low rank error so
typically you think of error and kind of
how many ranks was i off by
but when you think about value error if
you're looking at a long tail these
might be really large values or really
small values
this thing increases a lot so even if
it's a low percentage change
that that blows up uh when you're in
kind of
the the tail end of your distributions
um
and the cool thing about using sketches
is that
you can kind of customize how you want
to treat error
across rank and this is i think where
the magic comes in so on the left we
have kind of our default setting
for the sketch we kind of say
we want to treat error kind of evenly uh
absolute error evenly across
all of the possible ranks so even on the
long end of the tail uh the long tails
um and in the middle uh the only place
that you'll see it's really low is right
at each end and that's because the
sketching techniques do keep track of
the actual min and the actual max
but then you can also think about
customizing this so let's say i um the
the rare events that i'm going to run
into
or the real issues that we have the real
cost
comes when the rank is high or when the
values are really high on my
distribution
so
i might have an application where
if yeah if i encounter a really really
high
loan amount um
having errors for this is is more
problematic than somewhere else
um and so we might want to reduce the
um the error that we expect here for the
high end of
the ranks and then leave the other end
alone
or customize this based on
kind of the needs of your particular
application
any question on um
this otherwise i'll go forward and kind
of wrap up here
oh yeah absolutely
uh so this maybe i'll come back to
oh i guess it it's this isn't a great
picture for it so i'll just uh sketch
out the intuition a bit um but
essentially um what happens is that
you're keeping track of
a certain kind of small list of numbers
and then a number of metrics so this
kind of weight metric
for different points in um
in the list of numbers and the samples
that you have um and so because you only
need those weights
you can
essentially you lay these two
you can lay these two samples on top of
each other
and describe kind of
ranked terms so um between the like
let's say zero to 25th
um or 25 percentile uh this is how much
i need to
adjust the
values when i give a query so like
essentially all we're doing is we're
defining a sample and we're defining uh
between a fixed interval between 0 and 1
how much you need to adjust the values
for because they're all in this adjust
like this fixed interval it means that
you can easily stack them on top of each
other
and
and come out with a
new adjustment factor that accounts for
both
all right um
so i'll go forward and then we can
finish with questions
um so yeah if if you uh want to try this
you can um kind of there's really cool
ways we can extend this and have this
information use this information for
metrics
kind of statistical tests those sorts of
things
and yeah i'll just go to the question
slide and
finish off with any questions that you
guys have
[Applause]
you